[Music]
lightweight fast highly available this
is how serverless is often described
insult true but making your solution
reliable and performance depends also on
you
hi I'm Slovak I work as a software
engineer in the cloud functions team at
Google and together with my colleague
Marek we'll talk about ways to build
solid production systems with cloud
functions now cloud functions is an
event-driven serverless compute platform
someone or something generates an event
and your code your function is executed
as a result of it this is pretty much
the simplest way to run your code in the
cloud there are no servers to be
provisioned managed patched or updated
you pay only Wyler code runs you can
connect and extend multiple cloud
services and finally cloud functions
automatically scale are highly available
and fault tolerant but does it mean that
all your potential problems with
availability and performance are
automatically resolved the answer is not
completely as you can still apply
multiple best practices to build a
robust system and we're going to talk
about them in this talk first we'll
cover reliability improvements then
we'll move on to performance
optimizations and additionally we will
also discuss observability which is
important when you want to know what is
going on with your system let's start
with talking over reliability
improvements through making your cloud
function retrial and idempotent we first
need to realize that in distributed
systems failures happen
in fact they are an inherent part of
such systems as it's practically
impossible to build a solid production
system or any complex system in which
errors do not occur at all the only way
we can handle them is to make sure that
we handle the errors graceful and cloud
platform actually provides significant
help in handling such errors it is
actually one of the big benefits of
using cloud and serverless solutions
however your software still needs to be
prepared for error scenarios if we think
about who ensures reliability of your
software running in the cloud we realize
that reliability must be a shared goal
across cloud platform and your solution
when you use a Google cloud service
Google takes care of its reliability for
example when you call a cloud vision API
Google makes sure that the service is
available and can handle your requests
when you upload a file to the cloud
storage Google make sure it's persisted
using replication under the hood when
you create your service in the cloud
Google still helps you build a robust
system but you are in control of its
overall reliability for example your
function may fail if it includes a bug a
call to your other service may also fail
if that service returns an error or is
flaky how to ensure reliability of your
cloud function as we already know
functions are good for processing events
in particular they're a great tool when
connecting different services for
example when processing the incoming
data and upload it uploading it to a
storage system in the success scenario
everything works the data is processed
and then persisted for example in a
database
but what if an error occurs in this
process your function may run out of
memory and network connectivity issue
may happen you may get an error response
from the service on which you depend all
these issues may potentially result in
data loss if the data doesn't make it to
its destination how to handle problems
like this retries are an important
strategy here in a distributed system it
is normal that the services on which
your function depends are not always
100% available as a result your function
may fail occasionally
the simplest way to handle failures in
serverless
is to retry function executions however
you should not force your users to retry
requests to your system but instead use
you should configure your system to
perform retrace automatically when
needed cult functions come into distinct
variants HTTP functions are invoked by
standard HTTP requests which wait for
HTTP response from the function
background functions are invoked by
events events from the clouds like
messages on a cloud pub/sub topic or
changes in a cloud storage bucket all
functions are known are normally invoked
once for an event unless an error occurs
and here is where the two variants of
cloud functions offer different
execution guarantees HTTP functions are
executed at most once due to their
synchronous nature this means that the
calls are not retried by cloud functions
and it is the caller who must handle any
errors and if you think about it the
caller should handle the errors anyway
as the request might not even reach
Google's infrastructure on the other
hand background functions are executed
at least once
as asynchronous function executions
triggered by events can be retried by
cloud functions as there is no caller
who could do it otherwise let's look at
some examples this is an HTTP function
which calls another service to upload
payload from the HTTP requests it simply
sends a post request to that service
easy right the problem is that the call
to the other service may fail for
whatever reason for example network
connectivity issue and this would result
in the function failure and if the
function isn't retried then the data may
be dropped on the floor in case of HTTP
functions the call should be reached
right by the caller so you can change
your colors code to either implement
your own retry logic or use an existing
library or a module that can perform
retries for you for example in this case
the promised retry module retries the
calls to - cloud function because we
returned the the request promise
inside inside the promised retry call
this is a simple background function it
also uploads data to another system
this time it extracts the contents from
the cloud pub/sub message payload
similar problem here if the dependent
service fails the function will fail
because we returned the promise as the
function result in case of background
functions retries should be configured
on function deployment either through
cloud SDK or cloud console by enabling
the retry on failure option
this way your function will be retried
until it succeeds the first three try
happen almost immediately after first
function execution the next three tries
follow the exponential back-off policy
kept at ten seconds and they happen for
up to seven days if your function keeps
failing however you should be careful
with using this option because it will
retry your function on any error also if
it is caused by a bug or some unexpected
input data so if you use this option you
should return errors from your function
only on transient issues and preferably
handle the permanent problems inside the
functions completely so in general there
are multiple places to apply retrace as
we saw you can retry calls to an HTTP
function you can configure it tries over
background functions you can also retry
calls to dependent systems from inside
the function for example by configuring
the client libraries that you use you
can search for what options they offer
or you can write custom code and finally
as already mentioned persistent errors
should be distinguished from transient
failures and three tried retrace should
be applied only on the latter ones let's
look at a bit more complex example now
here's a function which processes the
data and writes it to two storage
systems first to the upper one and then
to the lower one the problem is as you
might expect that any of the uploads may
fail
for example let's assume that they
upload to the second storage failed well
in this case the data would not be saved
in the storage but we know how to handle
this right apply retrace but our retrace
always save
for example here if we apply retrace the
second function execution will result in
storing the data in the second storage
assuming that the upload succeeds this
time however the first storage will
receive a duplicate because they upload
to the first storage will be retried and
duplicates introduce consistency
inconsistencies they are not good so we
don't want them can we do anything to
prepare the function for each write
executions to avoid issues like data
duplication the answer is yes and the
concept of idempotency comes in handy
here a function is considered
idempotence if an event results in the
desired outcome and side-effects even if
the function is invoked multiple times
for the same event
so making a function idempotent is
actually required to behave to make it
behave correctly on rich right execution
attempts let's look at an Oneida patan
function first this function uploads the
received contents to fire store first
and then it uploads the same contents to
another service by sending a post
request one potential problem here is
that if the upload to the fire store
succeeds and the upload to the other
service fails and the function is
retried another document with the same
contents will be added to fire store so
have a duplicate which can also be seen
in the fire store database viewer but
this may also happen if the fire store
was replaced with another system and we
as we know we don't want duplicate they
may introduce further inconsistencies
they may cause accounting problems the
users may be confused they are not good
to solve this problem we'll use event ID
this is a number which uniquely
identifies each event and what is
important here is that even if the
function execution is retried for the
same event the event ID itself remains
unchanged
how do we use it in our code we first
extract the event ID from the event
context and then we use it as a Fire's
as the firestore document ID this way if
the function is retried it will not add
a duplicate object to firestore a
duplicate document instead it will
overwrite the existing document which
exists under the same event ID with the
same contents anyway
similarly some other systems also
support so-called idempotency keys and
if the system that you use supports them
you can use event ID as the idempotency
key as a result we no longer observe
duplicates and the firestore and
similarly we wouldn't observe duplicates
in other systems to which we passed
event ID as the idempotency key but what
if the system on which we depends does
not support item fantasy here is an
example this is a function which uses
SendGrid the email delivery service to
send an email from the function the
problem is that the sent call is not
idempotent what can we do about it we
can record event IDs this is the general
approach here we use a database like
fire store in this example but other
database could work as well to store the
already handled event IDs and then when
the requests come before we enter the
non-id bottle section of the code so the
one which sends an email and if it was
retried it could result in duplicate
emails being sent in this section we
first check
by querying firestar where whether the
events was handled and if it was not we
execute the non-id button section and
then store the event ID as handled in
the firestore database this way the
chance of unwanted retried calls to the
other service of the duplicate emails
being sent are greatly reduced however
there is still small chance that if the
function attempts are executed
concurrently a duplicate emails may
still be sent to practically resolve
this issue we can use the LEAs mechanism
it allows us to get an exclusive access
to the non-id upon a section of the code
for the specific amount of time in this
example the first attempt gets the lease
before it enters the critical section
the one that sends the email the second
attempt which happens while the least
icon is actually rejected because it
cannot get the lease and finally the
third attempt which happens after the
first attempt failed takes the lease
again and eventually succeeds with
handling the event how do we apply this
approach to our code we use a fire start
transaction and this time it's not only
checks whether the given event has been
handled but it also saves the timestamp
until which the current function
execution has exclusive access to the
critical section again the one which
sends the email if another request comes
before this timestamp I mean another
retry of the same function it will be
rejected so no concurrent code execution
will happen and with this approach
applied we practically eliminated the
unwanted retries
so to summarize there are multiple ways
to make your function idempotent you can
ensure that your mutations can happen
more than once without changing the
outcome you can record which event IDs
have already been processed you can
query database state in the transaction
before mutating the state you can also
supply other policy keys when calling
API switch supported which support them
and finally you can also clean up
duplicates out-of-band through an
offline process if that approach is fine
in your world in your workflow
alright so to see retries and Ida policy
in action I will demonstrate a simple
order processing system for my fake
restaurant called kale pizza how does it
look like going from the left side of
the diagram there is a website through
which customers can create orders the
website invokes one cloud function which
publishes a message to cloud pub/sub
topic then there is another function
which is triggered on messages from this
topic and does three things first it
calls another service represented by
another function which chooses the cook
who's going to handle the given order
then it stores the order together with
the selected cook in the fire store
database and then it calls yet another
service yet another function which
triggers meal preparation and finally
the restaurant has a website which
simply syncs with the firestore database
to view the incoming orders alright so
let's see this in action
okay so I will click start right away
and here we have this two website so one
is the client side website and the other
one is the restaurant side website so
the one on the Left generates the event
I'm generating than every second here -
to see more of these events going out -
to make it more interesting and let's
see what we get here so far so good
all the retries are going through okay
let's wait a bit more all right let's
stop it so what do we see now 44 orders
went out and only 41 orders came in so
some orders got lost here and I can see
that for example the first one here
right it didn't make it to the to the
restaurant it didn't make it through the
whole pipeline so something is wrong
here and lost orders means unhappy
customers not good for your business
so let's investigate what happens so I
have the functions deployed in my
project and the main function the one
which performs those three actions is
the process order function and like I
show on the diagram it does three things
it calls the truth cook service then it
stores the order in the database and
then it calls yet another service so
probably something failed here so let's
see and here is were the observability
tools in Google cloud platforms are
invoked in Google cloud platform are
useful first I can see that on the
executions chart there are some errors
indeed right most requests were okay but
there are also some errors
and if I scroll down I can see the
errors from the last seven days and if I
click here it I go to stock driver error
reporting and which I can see the errors
chart I can see a sample stuck trace and
finally I can see some logs
okay let's let's go to this one or this
one
I can click view logs and see the logs
here alright so if I filter only by this
execution ID I can see a simple function
invocation so the function execution
started received an order but then it
got it got the transient failure from
the choose cook service and if we look
at the implementation of the choice cook
function we can see that it's
implemented in a way that only succeeds
90% of the time for the remaining 10% it
fails of course this is a synthetic
example of a failing service but as I
said you you should assume that the
function that you are calling or the
service that you are calling may may
fail for for many reasons and similar
story about the other function prepare
meal it also has the success ratio of
90% only alright so we know what
happened and we know how to handle
transient issues right we can apply
retrace so I have the second version of
this function here process or the retry
with the same source code it does the
same things but it has the retry on
failure option enabled I use this option
when deploying the function so let's see
how this one works
let's switch to the topic cloud pub/sub
topic and fire store collection which
actually are operated on by this second
version of the function
alright so I've got orders going out
orders coming in by the way the colors
are just color encoded event ID so that
we can visually compare the right and
left side
see the differences okay I can stop and
what do I see
26 orders went out and 30 orders came in
so this okay 31 31 orders came in so
definitely more than I census there must
be some duplicates and I can already see
some here which was which appears even
three times the same order the same
event IDs with three different cooks
assigned so then we start preparing the
meal right away well the customer may be
happy with the extra two meals but still
that's not good for your business so
what can we do to avoid loose duplicates
and the answer is introduced idempotency
so I have the third version of the
function here and this time I modified
the source code and the piece that I
modified is the one which runs which
stores the order in fire store so I
introduced a transaction which first
checks whether the given event ID
whether the document with the given
event ID or in this case the order ID
was already processed and only added to
the I only added to fire store if it was
not if it does not exist yet
this way I'll also prevent the issue of
overriding the same order with a
different cook assigned so let's see how
this one warps so I have the third
version here let's start generating the
events all right it takes some time to
process them we should start seeing them
here all right they're coming in let's
wait a bit more to see if we get the
desired results so far so good
order sketching up
yep okay so 29 orders generated Twain I
thought orders came in so no lost orders
and no duplicates and I'd like to
highlight that I didn't touch the
services that were flaky that failed for
10% of the time but instead i
reconfigured the other parts of the
system to handle this situation in a
good way moving on I'd like to summarize
the first part of the talk saying that
you should introduce retries and make
your function idempotence to make to
improve reliability of your functions
thank you and with this i would like to
introduce my colleague mark who is going
to cover the second part of the talk
about performance optimizations Thank
You Sadiq thank you I'm very happy to be
here with you I I wonder how many of you
actually use called functions or have
tried called functions okay so this is
gonna be a little bit it's not the basic
topic so I assume that all of you know
what the cost art is so I assume that
all of you know that the cost out is
when the infrastructures means up a new
instance that will execute the code of
your function and you probably know that
this happens if there's no instance that
is serving the traffic or maybe that
there is a southern surge in the number
of requests that your function has to
handle and then there must be many
instances executing at the same time
you've probably heard a functional
stateless and that's because there are
so many instances that came came in and
came out come out and that's true but
the fact is that they are not always
titleist which means that if there is an
instance that is serving it's probably
going to be reused for future
invocations for
subsequent calls and this lets you reuse
the state that the instance has to
improve performance and I will show you
in a little bit how you can do that so
the first example is connections let's
assume that your function has has to
connect to some external system and you
can improve performance by maintaining
persistent connections so you establish
the connection at the first function
invocation in in the instance that is
serving and then subsequent calls that
will hit the same instance are going to
to have the connection established so
this may not be so important if the
system that you connect to is in the
same data center or very close but it's
very important if the system that you
are connecting to is on the other side
of the world and then the connection
establishment actually takes time a
small caveat here is that you have to be
careful with the target system that you
you are connecting to because it may
have a limit on the number of
connections that it can handle and if
you use persistent connections any
instance of the function that is
actually out there serving will maintain
the connection so a it may exhaust the
connection pool of the target system
going farther the same principle may
apply to API objects and such API
objects very often have connections
inside somewhere so it's very useful to
declare those API objects on the global
scope in your in the code so that the
connection is not very established every
time you create the API object similarly
if there is a global variable that gets
recomputed every time your function is
called it's useful to put it into the
global scope so that it's computed once
and then reused all of subsequent
invocations but on the other hand it's
not always true that it's better to
perform those computations in in the
global scope when on the cold start
because it may happen that the the value
is not even used so if you use the value
under very rare conditions it's better
to compute it lazily and not in the
culture because the best optimization is
when you just remove the code that is
not used and this is especially
important if your function if you
declare several functions in the same
file a which you can do and actually
many people that everyone that uses
firebase probably did that because this
is the common way how firebase functions
are written and if you do that you have
to know that every function runs in a
separate set of instances so if an
instance handles the execute invocations
of the first function it will never be
called to execute the second function
because that's a separate set of
distances so if you use eval if you
initialize a very heavy variable that is
used in the second function in the
global scope it's just a waste of time
and that also applies to those require
statements nodejs where you include
libraries that you are going to use so
it's a big awkward to require libraries
inside the function but if you declare
multiple function in the same file
that's the performance optimization
when you apply this kind of
optimizations please be mindful that the
function runs only until the callback is
called
if you try to execute something after
it's called
there will be no CPU actually to do that
and the code will not progress so it may
be tempting to write the code like this
to send the result of the customer to
the user and then do some computations
to optimize for subsequent invocations
but don't do that it will not work I've
told you about cashing some computations
inside functions in the global scope
inside node.js process but you can use
also a local file system where you can
write files and those files will survive
on this particular instance as long as
as the instance is alive and disturbing
but you have to be careful here because
at the file system is in in memory so
it's it's not infinite and every file
that you write is going to consume the
memory the runtime memory of your
function so eventually if you if on
every invocation you create a new file
and you forget to delete them you will
run up to run out of memory and when you
run out of memory your instance we die
and this means that there will be a cold
start for future invocations and of
course when there is a cold start you
lose the state that you carefully
prepared inside this instance to
optimize for subsequent invocations so
it's better to avoid them and you can
avoid them by taking care of not
exceeding the allocated memory not
throwing any occult uncaught exceptions
that can catch those exceptions and
because sometimes the process that's
executed the code may actually crash
that also causes a cold start and when
your function times out also the
instance is put down and another one is
started
this always about caching computations
inside the instance that execute your
code and this cache this state is
available all only for for this
particular instance so you have to
recompute it in every other instances
it's also possible to go a little bit
further to share some state across all
the instances but for that you need to
use some database for instance a several
s database like firestorm so the summary
for for this part of the talk is that
you can leverage the state of instances
to speed up subsequent invocations and
I'm going to show you an example how I
managed to optimize a little bit of my
application to just serve faster and the
application that I prepared is a
converting text or images so it's
applying caption on on a picture and the
parameters of the functions are just to
that caption to be written and whether
we want some background or not and we
have very awkward users that's most
often they don't want any background
users prefer white picture and we are
going to optimize for this for this use
case so the function does is first it
fetches the background fork from cloud
storage then it applies the caption
using imagemagick and finally it uploads
the result also to cloud storage the
code is simple exactly as you'd probably
imagined so create a temporary directory
download the background file load the
file into memory draw the caption write
the file to disk and upload it to cloud
storage very simple right
and when we debug our distributed
application where we analyze what
happens in such an application it's very
we just have to use the platform tools
to observe what's going on so we are
going to use cloud login and monitoring
to see either logs from individual
unifications or plots of some patterns
that are in our system it's father calls
other dimensions error reporting when
you can see errors grouped by error
types and you can directly go to logs
and in the context of monitoring you can
also set up others on certain thresholds
of metrics and other conditions and so
the first thing that we do is we deploy
our function and test it at scale in our
case the scale will be just 5 QPS for 5
minutes but yeah I think that's enough
for testing at when we start that we
soon realize that we have quite a lot of
errors it's about 5% and when we look at
the plot of memory usage we see that the
memory actually goes quite high it
reaches the limit of 500 if of 256
megabytes that we allocated to the
function so probably we miss configured
our instances we just gave them too
little memory and image processing
requires the memory to load the image so
proudly we just need to improve on that
but let's first check whether this is
indeed the case that the errors were
because of memory ran out so let's go to
the function page and let's view logs
when if we filter the logs by error type
we immediately see that those errors
were memory exceeded errors so of course
we add more memory we reckon redeploy
the instance with a larger amount of
memory and we test it again and what
happens
luckily the errors went down to 2% but
they are not completely gone it's still
something still wrong and we see that
the memory usage actually went up in the
second test it went up even up to 500
mega
which is allocated so it looks like we
have a memory leak and I would let you
look at the code and maybe somebody can
find what the memory what the memory is
does anybody see the error here okay one
person sees an error let's see if others
see it second one okay very good okay
okay so some of you already know that
the problem is that we create a
temporary file and we don't delete it at
the end so the temporary file is created
here there is we just generate a random
string for the file that we are going to
generate and it has generated we write
it to disk and we never delete it so
this is the this is this works as I
described it the first part that
whenever you write something to your
local storage it's consuming your memory
so it's very easy to fix we actually
just need to delete the file because we
before we finish the function and that's
the fix that we applied and with this
memory leak fixed we admittedly see that
firstly we don't have any five hundreds
no errors and also the memory usage went
down even below this 256 limit that we
applied before so the question is shall
we now reduce the amount of memory for
the function or not but let's take a
look at the performance we see that with
more memory our function actually runs
faster and that's because this is how we
allocate CPU to functions the more
memory the function has the most CPU it
also gets and giving twice more memory
gives also twice more CPU so your
function runs faster and in our case we
would like to have the system quite
performance so two seconds of latency is
probably quite good but for seconds it's
a lot too much so let's let's stick to
this instant size and this amount of CPU
in further work so now let's take a
closer look where the function actually
spends time on what's the most costly
part so we go to cloud logging we select
an individual ego invocation we click on
it and then we can filter logs from just
one invocation and you can see that the
majority of time is spent on uploading
the file to cloud storage that's quite
surprising Google has good Network why
would that beat so slow and the fact is
that we actually used very bad
compression type and by the way this is
a not a very good idea to look at one
individual invocation to analyze what's
going on in a distributed application
because this may be just some random
problems here and maybe in other cases
everything will work fine so it's much
better to report custom metrics to stock
driver for instance and look at the
behavior at scale but in our case locks
it gave us this information so the
problem with uploading cloud to cloud
storage was that the files were big we
use BMP file images which were about
seven megabytes while PNG took only 10
kilobytes so the first optimization that
we can apply is to switch the
compression from BMP to PNG very simple
and by the way also this uploading speed
depends on the instance size because
uploading data requires a little bit of
the CPU so you can also improve on that
by giving the instance more memory and
more CPU so we when we change the
compression time type a our function is
faster almost twice much better can we
do better of course I mentioned that our
users are a bit weird that they don't
like backgrounds they like black and
white so we don't really have to
download the background image on every
invocation let's just not do that and
this actually detect the case that I
tested without any background just like
and white
so we can now download the background
only when it's needed and we can
download it only once and with this
optimization we safe at another 50
milliseconds and some of you may have
noticed that on some previous slides it
was 90 milliseconds or 84 for this face
for downloading the the background and
this is what I mentioned that one
individual invocation will not give you
a precise data we need to have multiple
invocations of that's why metrics are
always better than individual logs from
one invocation so now we can also
imagine that it's useful to move
computations that are that can be done
just once to global scope so in the next
step I'll I moved creating of the
temporary directory into the global
scope and creating the Jesus bucket
object which is this we always use the
same bucket for uploading the image and
also for double on the background so we
can you just move those two lines into
the global scope and that will sell you
another 25 milliseconds not so much but
still significant maybe more happy users
so to summarize what we did here we
fixed firstly we fixed the memory leak
in our application we increase the
instance size to give it more CPU we use
better compression so that we don't
spend so much CPU time on uploading
images to cloud storage will a easy
download the background image because it
wasn't used in only vocations and
finally we moved some computations to
the global scope so that is performed
only once and while doing that we use
the platform tools to observe our
systems we use a logging used monitoring
maybe we didn't use logging in the best
way we could have used more monitoring
and and that's about that but we still
have time to answer your questions
[Music]